lawmakers are taking steps to force
Facebook and other online platforms to
disclose who buys political ads on their
sites Facebook revealed Russian agents
bought roughly 3000 ads for about
$100,000 during the 2016 campaign Google
sold nearly five thousand dollars in ads
to Russian operatives federal law bars
foreign groups from spending money to
influence American elections a new
bipartisan bill called the honest as Act
would make online advertisers disclose
who paid for ads just like they do in
radio and TV right now CBS News
contributor Nicholas Thompson is
editor-in-chief of Wired magazine and
joins us at the table Nick always good
to see you it is you Gail listen we like
anything the sound of anything
bipartisan but do you think that this
will will actually make a difference in
the elections this bill this is a very
good bill it will make a difference it
does close a loophole
absolutely Internet ads should be
regulated just like other political ads
do I hear a but but it's a small step
this isn't how Russia influence the
election it's not how Russia influence
the election on social media there are
much bigger problems on social media but
still this should be done who will
oppose it well you could imagine the ad
networks will oppose it because it will
add a little bit of bureaucracy it's
possible that the tech companies will
oppose it though ultimately it might be
good for them to have a little more
regulation Facebook was obviously hurt
massively but what happened in the next
election so those two groups and also
people who don't want any kind of
campaign finance reform so you can see
some Republicans opposing it on that
ground how many millions of people does
Facebook say this reached well the
number of people who are reached by
Russian political ads is a fairly small
number right I mean it's a couple of
million people and ten million right
yeah
and reaches a very broad definition
right you know it to reach someone just
means you scroll through it doesn't
really mean you reach them in any
substantial way what's interesting here
is that the online political ads are
there it is something that happened but
what's really problematic are the fake
accounts that the Russian operatives set
up those were massively more influential
and they're harder to find and harder to
define but that's the biggest problem
that's the thing that had more influence
last night Silicon Valley continued to
have a PR problem so Logan guy has a
massive
pyaare problem a growing PR problem and
one that they're really struggling with
right now and how they respond to this
bill will play into that if they come
out hard against it you can imagine
people getting even angrier so I tried
to get Facebook to say something to me
last night about and I really got I got
nothing mm-hmm
Nick Thompson thank you in a statement
to CBS News Facebook said we stand with
lawmakers in their effort to achieve
transparency in political advertising